if we don't get Stargate now when will
we and what is the risk if they leave it
much longer welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and with your Channel
[Music]
[Music]
so look there are a lot of rumors
banging around about Stargate at the
moment and we're talking a lot about it
on this channel but that's because you
know as the news comes in I'm going to
share with you as quickly as I can
but I just want to highlight very
quickly in this short video something
that I told you a little while ago
I was told by a source close to MGM and
now Amazon that if we didn't get
Stargate by Spring 2023 that we might
not get it at all or at the very least
that it might be years and that actually
the longer we wait the more likely it is
that we're going to get a hard reboot of
the franchise so I just wanted to talk
to you really quickly about this risk
and How likely I think it is to happen
so why if we don't get it now are we
more at risk of getting a hard reboot
further down the line well obviously
it's only been just over a decade since
SGU was canceled it's still reasonably
fresh in our memories a hard reboot now
would be unpopular with fans a lot of
fans that are still hoping for that
continuation still hoping for a
continuation with Brad Wright at the
helm
But as time goes by people will start to
become more open to a hard reboot and to
be honest as well a pool of new fans
fans that never watch Stargate round the
first time gets bigger so as time goes
by the chances that they just decide to
reboot the whole thing become more
likely but obviously also from a
pragmatic point of view it becomes more
sensible to do a hard reboot as time
goes by because people just won't
remember what came before too much time
will have passed now if you look at sort
of the Quantum Leap reboot now that had
a good couple of decades between Scott
Bakula stepping into the quantum
accelerator and the new series now they
did that as a continuation kind of it's
a standalone series you never really had
to watch the original to understand they
explain everything all over again it's
completely new characters it's a soft
reboot in the same universe
but the point is that the fans of the
original can still get on board with
this because it's not a hard reboot it's
a continuation and they tease us with
the hope that they might bring in
elements from the original series into
this new series at some point now they
could do something like that with
Stargate right now
But as time goes by it would
particularly with it being a Sci-Fi
franchise it's more likely a hard reboot
would be the way to go and to be honest
it would just make more sense and would
be much easier for the new producers of
the show to do just look at Battlestar
Galactica for example it was very much a
show set in the 80s
um the special effects and so on and so
on now they took elements from that show
and moved it into the new show exactly
for example the Viper and so on
but it was a completely new hard reboot
new telling of the story they modernize
aspects of the story they brought it up
to date with what audiences at the time
oh God even that shows 10 years old
there but with the audience at the time
expected now the longer we go without
Stargate the more likely it is that
Executives will decide to go down that
route and decide that it's actually the
only route that's viable we might get
sort of a continuation kind of like
they've done with Quantum Leap or we may
just go to completely reimagining but
either way the risk increases the longer
we wait if you're new to the channel
like subscribe hit the Bell notification
do all of that stuff you know you're
supposed to do but also visit
sidehashtrack.com where you can get
merch like this I love this new design I
love this t-shirt it's awesome and the
mug in particular is Ace but you can
also get the new design the sleeping
giant of sci-fi get a t-shirt get a hat
get whatever the hell you like it all
helps to support the channel
right now though the chances of us
actually getting a just a continuation
of the story it will still be a soft
reboot in a way that will still be new
characters but it'll be the existing
universe is very high negotiations are
going on conversations are going on with
new producers to produce a new TV show
and potentially a couple of movies
so we still have to cross our fingers
but I just wanted to put out there the
concern and my worry that if we don't
hear anything by late spring of 2023 by
saying April May
then we're gonna have to start preparing
ourselves for the fact that it might
actually be another 10 years until we
see Stargate and even then it might be a
hard reboot
please guys again for the comments and
tell me what you think I would love to
know your opinion this is a channel for
conversation and debate an opinion after
all so get in the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also if you support the
channel and you want to support us even
more consider hitting that join Button
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]